il ya un peu partout des régimes qui
sont de plus en plus autoritaire il ya
de plus en plus une réduction réalité
peut dire de toute forme de vie publique
en dehors de l'action de ces deux
gouvernements
donc alors l'appel sa populisme mais ya
aucune raison qu'on a fait dire pourquoi
est ce qu'on dit que trump et populiste
corbani populistes ou que sais je bats
non ce sont des gens qui participe à une
espèce de et d'évolution de nos formes
d'état un peu partout quoi bon et puis
là on appelle populisme n'est autre
chose à savoir qu'elle puisse bien
quelque chose comme une sorte d'effet
pop tire justement produit
automatiquement par le régime
représentatif parce que précisément le
régime représentatif dit voilà il ya le
peuple
bien des gens qui le représente alors
bon que lorsqu'on voit que les gens qui
représente le peuple c'est en réalité
dans la petite minorité du parti du
gouvernement
cette petite mine de cette petite
minorité là en fait donc passer
c'est quoi ces 10% de la population que
cette banque disons c'est que cette
minorité la bomba tison suivons les
ordres des désordres dit qu'ils viennent
de demande en eau que disons
essentiellement pire gouvernement qu'il
soit de gauche et ou de droite pour
appliquer essentiellement un même agenda
bon quel agenda dit néolibérale donc un
agenda de transformation un petit peu de
toutes les formes de la dite collective
pour qu'elle dise ont obéi c'est la
seule loi du marché quoi lorsqu'on voit
ça bien que brawn on se trouve si non à
cette situation où d'un côté on vous dit
le peuple est souverain et nous leur
présentons quoi et puis en même temps
ils iraient y aller de plus en plus
comme une sorte d'évidence créée par le
système lui-même que ben non que c'est
que c'est pas vrai quoi la partir de là
qu'ils ont effectivement il ya des gens
qui disent à l'aiea mais attention nous
on est le vrai peuple où on représente
le vrai peuple alors on crée autour de
la halle espèce de fantasme si vous
voulez encore une fois d'un bon d'un
peuple qui serait le vrai peuple d'en
bas que ces jeux que ça j'ai encore
auquel on prête ou des vertus ou davis
que ces gens tout cas pas beaucoup qu'on
traite comme cet épais de le de gros
animal bon disons platon parler du
démocratie comme du peuple comme le gros
animal qu une certaine façon on
reconstitue un peu cette espèce d'image
du gros année du gros animal est
évidemment on voit bien attirer aussi
c'est que au fond toutes les met toutes
les dérives autoritaires de nos
gouvernements
baho disons mais on peut dire merci à
cause du peuple ça c'est à cause du
peuple
finalement pourquoi il ya moins de
démocratie parce que parce que le peuple
n'en veut pas c'est parce que le peuple
réclame de l'autorité le peuple réclame
de la répression et le peuple réclame
quand il est confisqué les migrants
confie damien les migrants à la porte
voilà donc voilà je dirais qu'il ya ce
jeu en quelque sorte que dire entre deux
manières dont le mot populisme est
utilisé avec une espèce de boucle
finalement qui est que bon il ya
toujours un peuple des profondeurs
supposer un peu comme sa brutale
ignorante à la banque et qui finalement
sert à justifier
bon les dérives de plus en plus
oligarchique et autoritaire de le
gouvernement
[Musique]